[Musique]
c'est dans la fraîcheur des hauts sur
les pentes du tévelave qui est installé
rené paul lépine est un producteur de
fraises p6 et annabelle comme variété on
n'a pas vraiment ce sont les toutes
premières fraises de la saison qui sont
récoltées ici depuis une trentaine
d'années rené paul et sa femme exploite
quatre serres de production
la fraise toute une tradition dans la
famille nature a fait pour soutenir la
production locale de fruits et légumes
le département aide les producteurs
indépendants comme renée paule pour un
tonnage minimale de 5 tonnes de fraises
par an cet agriculteur disposera d'une
subvention de 3000 euros
ayed a financé des plans d'un fumeur
comme scania nike ou sur les plans
puisque d'habitude est plein ils
rentrent pas bateau mais cette année la
gamme pro bien failli fait rentrer par
avion
donc moi y'a 6 au coût de 1000 euros sur
les plans donc il
et ce sont les agents de la cellule
agricoles du département qui
accompagnent ces agriculteurs dans la
réalisation et le suivi de leur dossier
des aides à la production donc le
dossier il est préremplie ils écument
riposté et quand on arrive face à eux le
choix du rendez vous on les appelle au
moins trois fois avant de les rencontrer
pour pour être sûr d'avoir tous les
éléments nécessaires au montage du
dossier
et ce jour là ont rempli le dossier avec
eux on revoit un petit peu tous les
éléments constitutifs du dossier on
revoit toutes les pièces justificatives
et et puis on reste en contact avec eux
par la suite les deux mondes aide pour
la filière fruits et légumes sont
disponibles jusqu'au 30 juin
pendant ce temps les fraises cueillies à
maturité sous ses serres et pour notre
producteur pays cette saison ses fraises
sont aussi belles que sucre est très
bonne on bien sucré comme tous les ans
ici c'est de tous les ans et sont bonnes
comment j'ai l'espace de chercher les
pillards
[Musique]